what is the single most important habit
that you need to start to build that if
you look back in a year you could say
I'm so happy that I built this one habit
because it's helping you accomplish your
goals what is the most important habit
what is the one habit that you want to
start to build that if that one thing
happened your entire life starts to
change it's the Cornerstone habit that
you start doing that because I guarantee
you listen if you start waking up at a
certain time or you start working out
you pick any of them you start doing one
of those things that you're proud of
yourself for doing it other things start
to change in your life around you
because when you feel really proud of
yourself when you feel good about
yourself
other things start to improve too